auch wenn immer häufiger über psychische
gesundheit gesprochen wird leidet das
thema depression immer noch unter viel
stigmatisierungen oder falschen
vorurteilen also depressionen werden oft
gar nicht als krankheit ernst genommen
so nach dem motto sei doch nicht immer
so negativ
du musst dich einfach mal besser
ernähren und joggen hat mir total
geholfen ihr gut für juli aber dann hast
du halt auch keine depressionen
gleichzeitig ist eine depression ja auch
komplizierter als das was wir unter
einer rein körperlichen krankheit
verstehen was wären dort zum beispiel
die behandlung mit medikamenten meist
standard ist sind antidepressiva
umstrittene glücksbringer teuer und null
wirkung antidepressiva wirken kaum
besser als placebo
wir haben uns die studienlage mal etwas
genauer angeschaut und waren teilweise
selbst überrascht also wodurch ein thema
wir steigen durch in dem versuch diesem
thema gerecht zu werden ist dieses video
teil einer dreier funk kollabo wie viele
verschiedene gesichter einer depression
haben kann welche
behandlungsmöglichkeiten es gibt und so
weiter erfahrt ihr im video von pier von
psychologie und das team von true doko
hat mit theresa gesprochen die im kampf
gegen die depression eine spezielle
therapie gewählt hat und wir
beschäftigen uns wie gesagt mit
antidepressiva es ist interessant
während alle medikamente wirken indem
sie biochemisch in körpereigene prozesse
eingreifen ist es für viele
wahrscheinlich ein komisches gefühl
tabletten zu nehmen die einfluss auf die
stimmung oder die wahrnehmung haben im
gegensatz zu zb kopfschmerztabletten ich
will das nicht nehmen ich will einfach
nur ich bleiben ich will nicht auf
drogen gesetzt werden solche sorgen und
eine entsprechende abneigung gegen eine
medikamenten behandlung ist bei
antidepressiva wahrscheinlich stärker
als bei anderen medikamenten dabei ist
ja alles psychologische auch
gleichzeitig biologisch und wenn man
jetzt zum beispiel eine depression mit
kopfschmerzen vergleicht dann lösen
depressionen ja auch schmerzen aus wenn
auch komplexere oder abstraktere es gibt
ja wenn ich zwei große fragezeichen bei
antidepressiva erstens was sie die
nebenwirkungen aber vor
wirken die überhaupt für das kapitel
nebenwirkungen möchte ich euch auf
unsere schule zu verweisen
da haben wir paar sachen für euch
zusammen geschrieben natürlich ist es
sehr wichtig über nebenwirkungen gut
aufgeklärt zu sein aber nebenwirkungen
sind auch immer im verhältnis zu dem
leiden der krankheit zu sehen die
wirkungs frage ist aber natürlich ganz
grundlegend deswegen wollen wir uns in
diesem video darauf konzentrieren aber
bevor wir uns die studien anschauen
vorab ein paar kurze basics die
biochemie von antidepressiva die
geschichte der antidepressiva begann mit
einer zufälligen entdeckung einer
interessanten nebenwirkung 1952 wurde
ein neuer stoff gegen tuberkulose
getestet
bruni erzieht dieser stoff löste bei
einigen tuberkulosepatienten solche
euphorien aus dass sie ich zitiere frei
trotz löchern in der lunge über die
flure tanz wurde zunächst erstmal nur
als ungewöhnliche nebenwirkung
registriert und poliert zieht wäre sogar
fast als medikament zurückgezogen worden
aber nach und nach stellte sich heraus
das zeug heißt patienten die neben
tuberkulose oder einer chronischen
erkrankung unter weiteren problemen wie
ängstlichkeit erschöpfung oder
depressionen litten man fand heraus gibt
sieht ist also genannter mono amine ob
sie da silva kurz m&a hemmer und diese
im november wurden als medikamente
weiter entwickelt getestet und ab ende
der 50er jahre als antidepressiva
eingesetzt was genau machen jetzt solche
ma hemmer im körper naja sie hemmen emma
und was immer es im körper machen steckt
eigentlich schon im namen die endung
nase sagt uns das mono amine ob sie da
sie ein enzym ist und zwar ein enzym das
mona biene oxidiert anders gesagt wohne
amine abbaut das hier sind ein paar boni
amine die im gehirn eine wichtige rolle
spielen serotonin dopamin und
noradrenalin das sind alles
neurotransmitter also kommunikations
moleküle für gehirnzellen um mit die
konzentration dieser honorar mine zu
regeln gibt es im gehirn die bowle amino
oxidase also die ms
die diesem ohne amina abbauen wenn eine
mao hemmer ins spiel kommt wie dieser
abbau die hemd das heißt die
konzentration der mono amine steigt und
da immer hemmer gegen depressionen zu
helfen schienen lag die vermutung nahe
dass eine hohe konzentration von
serotonin dopamin und noradrenalin gegen
depressionen schützt diese theorie der
fehlende mona mine wird als mono amin
hypothese bezeichnet und nehmen den mmo
hämmern gibt es da auch die sogenannten
kritischen antidepressiva habt ihr
vielleicht auch schon mal gehört die
sind benannt nach ihrer chemischen
struktur die drei ringe enthält in den
60er jahren wurde die serotonin
hypothese aufgestellt die serotonin bzw
einen mangel an serotonin als ursache
von depressionen vermutet serotonin habt
ihr vielleicht auch schon mal gehört
wird als ein glückshormon bezeichnet
wobei diese bezeichnung diesem hormone
und neurotransmitter nicht gerecht wird
also über die verschiedenen funktionen
von serotonin könnte man ganzes video
machen der name serotonin deutet sich
davon ab dass es sich im blutserum
befindet und dort unter anderem dabei
hilft das herz kreislauf system zu
regulieren das meiste serotonin befindet
sich aber im magen-darm-trakt wo es
unter anderem die verdauung beeinflusst
und als neurotransmitter im gehirn
beeinflusst serotonin unter anderem
aufmerksamkeit schmerzempfindung und
stimmung mit dem fokus auf serotonin
wurde nun die nächste art von
antidepressiva entwickelt die heute auch
noch am häufigsten eingesetzt wird die
ssrs galactic civil toni update in
hitlers auf deutsch selektive serotonin
wiederaufnahmehemmer sperrige name macht
aber total sinn werdet ihr auch gleich
sehen wir brauchen nur ein paar
neurologische basics was wir
üblicherweise unter gehirnaktivität
verstehen spielt sich hauptsächlich
zwischen zwei nervenzellen oder
gehirnzellen ab zwischen denen liegt der
synaptischen spalt oder die synapse und
die nervenzellen kommunizieren über
diesen spalt hinweg durch moleküle also
durch neurotransmitter die sie hin und
herschicken neurotransmitter
wie serotonin also serotonin wird auf
der einen seite ausgeschüttet und auf
der anderen seite doktors an spezielle
serotonin rezeptoren an damit jetzt aber
aus diesem ich sag jetzt einfach mal
schwall aus serotonin ein kurzes
knackiges signal wird wird ein teil des
ausgeschütteten serotonins wieder aus
dem spalt abtransportiert
beziehungsweise von der nervenzelle auch
wieder aufgenommen also diese
wiederaufnahme des serotonins dient zur
regelung dieses gesprächs zwischen den
zellen was jetzt diese selektiven
serotonin wiederaufnahmehemmer machen
ist er jetzt ganz logisch sie hemmen die
wiederaufnahme von serotonin das heißt
die konzentration von serotonin erhöht
sich also anders gesagt könnte man es
auch als serotonin booster bezeichnen
doch obwohl ssrs die am häufigsten
eingesetzten antidepressiva sind ist die
serotonin hypothese alles andere als
rund denn der serotoninspiegel
tatsächlich eine zentrale rolle bei
einer depression spielt dann müssten ja
auch gesunde menschen
depressive symptome zeigen wenn man
ihren serotoninspiegel sinkt und
tatsächlich gibt es möglichkeiten den
serotoninspiegel künstlich zu senken zum
beispiel indem man jemandem eine
spezielle mischung von aminosäuren zu
trinken gibt doch diese studie zeigte
dass diese serotonin senkung keinen
einfluss auf die stimmung der teilnehmer
hatte außerdem obwohl es es schnell im
gehirn ankommen und auch nachweislich
schnell den serotoninspiegel erhöhen
das weiß es mehrere wochen bis die
medikamente auf die symptome einer
depression wirken es gibt mögliche
erklärungen für diese verzögerung
vielleicht muss ich das gehirn erst mal
auf diese neue konzentration einstellen
indem es zum beispiel neue rezepturen
ausbildet oder andere
physiologische veränderungen durchläuft
für die es aber etwas zeit braucht das
könnte auch der grund sein warum man bei
der vorherigen studie mit den gesunden
menschen keine effekte gesehen hat
vielleicht müsste meine serotoninspiegel
erst über mehrere wochen senken um
symptome zu sehen aber eigentlich reicht
auch schon allein ein blick in die
praxis um zu sehen dass sowohl die
monogamie newport asse als auch die
serotonin hypothese zu simpel gedacht
sind
denn sowohl anhänger als auch es ja es
sind lange nicht bei allen patienten
wirksam aber die forschung geht weiter
inzwischen gibt es antidepressiva die
ganz anders wirken als emma oder ssds zb
vitamin das wurde ursprünglich als
betäubungs und schmerzmittel eingesetzt
wird inzwischen aber auch als
antidepressivum verschreiben und
funktioniert indem es einen bestimmten
rezeptor im gehirn blockiert und zwar
den sogenannten nmda rezeptor dass es
kurz für n methyl die us part rezeptor
aber auch hier muss man sagen dass sich
eine depression nicht auch so etwas
einfaches wie einen in medias pataki
zepter reduzieren lässt ähnlich wie bei
den ssds sind die biochemischen
zusammenhänge noch nicht aufgeklärt und
in der praxis machen patienten auch ganz
unterschiedliche erfahrungen als judoka
erzählt theresa dass sie seit einer
ketamin therapie nach einem jahren einen
kampf zum ersten mal den eindruck hat
dass es ihnen endlich etwas besser geht
aber die suche nach einer passenden
behandlung oder behandlungs kombi ist
für betroffene und ärzte meistens ein
langer traffic also halten wir fest die
biochemie einer depression verstehen wir
bisher noch nicht zumindest nicht gut
genug wir haben einzelne puzzleteile uns
fehlt definitiv noch das große bild aber
selbst wenn man davon ausgeht dass der
serotoninspiegel oder der nmda rezeptor
bei einer depression nur eine rolle von
vielen spielen können antidepressiva ja
trotzdem helfen
indem sie einen speziellen aspekt
verbessern und damit die ganze
depression erträglicher machen oder
vielleicht können sie bei manchen
menschen besonders gut wirken auch wenn
es anderen vielleicht gar nicht hilft
die voraussetzung ist nur naja dass sie
überhaupt wirken viele klinische studien
wenige klare antworten zwischen
disclaimer wenn ihr das video schon
bisher angeschaut habt dann schaut bitte
auch wirklich den rest des videos bis
zum ende denn ich möchte vermeiden dass
irgendjemand mit unvollständigen infos
oder voreiligen schlüssen dieses video
verlässt es ist natürlich wertvoll
biochemische prozesse hinter krankheiten
genau zu verstehen um gezielte therapien
entwickeln zu können aber am ende muss
das alles getestet werden in klinische
studien also idealerweise in
kontrollierten randomisierten
doppelblinden studien die freunde der
sonne wissen bescheid trotzdem noch eine
kurze wiederholung
die studienteilnehmer sind menschen mit
einer depression und die werden
randomisiert sprich zufällig aufgeteilt
in eine testgruppe und eine
kontrollgruppe die testgruppe kriegt das
medikament die kontrollgruppe kriegt nur
ein placebo
und nur wenn das medikament besser wird
als das placebo ist eine wirksamkeit
nachgewiesen
übrigens auch wenn man die biochemischen
zusammenhänge gar nicht genau kennt und
auch die nebenwirkungen werden so
natürlich auch getestet solche
klinischen studien über antidepressiva
gibt es ziemlich viele doch 2008 sorgten
zwei meter analysen für großes aufsehen
und zwar zu recht lass mich kurz
ausholen denn das ist echt
brisant oder sagen wir so es gibt einen
wirklich einen neuen blick auf das ganze
ist ja normalerweise werden
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse als studien
in entsprechenden wissenschaftlichen
journal veröffentlichten letzten video
habe ich kurz darüber gesprochen dass zu
diesem publikations prozess eine
kritische prüfung der studien gehört
allerdings ist die wissenschaft
natürlich auch nicht frei von schwächen
zum beispiel gibt es das problem dass
negative ergebnisse zum beispiel ein
stoff hat keine wirkung gezeigt bei
einer bestimmten krankheit dass die erst
gar nicht veröffentlicht werden positiv
ergebnis hingegen die wir natürlich
veröffentlicht und sagen wir es gibt
fünf studien die zeigen jetzt eine
wirkung eines bestimmten medikaments
dann sieht es erst mal gut aus das ganze
sieht aber natürlich ganz anders aus
wenn es auf der anderen seite 50 studien
gibt die keine wirkung zeigen aber wenn
die nicht veröffentlicht werden
kriegen wir davon ja gar nichts mit
diese verzerrung nennt sich publication
bei es deswegen gibt es wenn man ein
neues medikament auf den markt bringen
möchte
die zulassungsbehörden die ihre eigenen
kontrollprozesse haben die verhindern
sollen dass ein unwegsames medikament
oder sogar ein gefährliches medikament
auf den markt kommt in den usa diese
zulassungsbehörde die fdp die food and
drug administration wird also ihre
eigenen kontrollmechanismen zum beispiel
müssen alle klinischen studien für neues
medikament vorab der fce gemeldet werden
damit man eben nicht negative ergebnisse
so im nachhinein unter tisch fallen
lassen kann dh der fdp liegen diese fti
registered studies und auch rohdaten vor
die in journals gar nicht unbedingt
veröffentlicht werden deswegen haben
sich diese amerikanischen
wissenschaftler gedacht da schauen wir
doch mal genauer hin und haben sich 74
fdj studies angeschaut in denen zwölf
antidepressiva an insgesamt zwölf
einhalb 1000 patienten getestet wurden
etwa ein drittel der studie sie auch
etwa ein drittel der patienten
beinhalteten wurden nicht in
wissenschaftlichen journals
veröffentlicht und die man ahnt es
hatten negative ergebnisse zum beispiel
dass das antidepressivum nicht besser
wird
als ein placebo das heißt jetzt
wohlgemerkt nicht dass auch die fdp also
die zulassungsbehörde diese negativen
studien ignoriert hat die wird natürlich
schon in die zulassungs beteiligung mit
einbezogen aber wenn man sich nur die
publizierten studien anschaut gibt es
natürlich ein verzerrtes viel
positiveres bild von der wirksamkeit von
antidepressiva dass auch patienten oder
ärzte beeinflussen kann
diese metaanalyse wurde im selben jahr
nachgelegt und schaute sich die fdp
studie noch einmal genauer an und kam zu
dem schluss dass antidepressiva bei
leichten oder mittelmäßigen depressionen
keine signifikante wirkung zeigen
sondern nur bei schweren depressionen
und auch da keine besonders große h
allerdings ist das jetzt auch schon
zwölf jahre her weiß man inzwischen mehr
2018 erschien diese studie der oxford
university im renommierten journal the
lancet die studien zu 21 depressiver und
zwar 522 kritische studien mit insgesamt
über 100 16.000 teilnehmern neue
auswertete
es ist die bisher größte meta analyse
inklusive einer sogenannten netzwerk
meta-analyse was ein starkes tool ist um
vereinfacht gesagt eigentlich nicht
vergleichbare studien doch miteinander
zu vergleichen das ergebnis alle
getesteten antidepressiva wirkten über
den placebo-effekt hinaus das heißt sie
verbesserten die symptome der teilnehmen
aber kurze zeit später erschien eine
kritische aufarbeitung dieser oxford
meta analyse vom nordic cochrane centre
in kopenhagen die wissenschaftler
kritisierten man hätte in der oxford
meta-analyse einige der klinischen
studien strenger bewerten müssen bei so
einer metaanalyse werden nämlich nicht
einfach alle studien gleichermaßen mit
einbezogen sondern sie werden nach ihrer
qualität und aussagekraft bewertet und
die hängt zum großen teil vom
studiendesign habt beispiel für blind in
einer ordentlichen doppelblindstudie
dürfen weder die teilnehmer noch die
behandelten ärzte noch die
wissenschaftler die daten auswerten
wissen wer in der
gruppen wären der kontrollgruppe ist
damit eben alles möglichst objektiv
bewertet werden kann erst wenn die daten
ausgewertet sind darf die verblendung
gelüftet wer denn jetzt aber ein
antidepressivum deutliche nebenwirkungen
hat zum beispiel durchfall
dann können die teilnehmer ja allein
daran merken dass in der testgruppe sind
oder auch die ärzte können merken dass
die patienten in der testgruppe sind und
so eine unbeabsichtigte entbindung kann
dazu führen dass eine wirkung größer
aussieht oder erscheint als sie
tatsächlich ist einer der kritikpunkte
der kopenhagener ist nun nur war eine
studie verblindet ist heißt das noch
lange nicht dass diese verbindung auch
funktioniert hat und anderer kritikpunkt
bezog sich zum beispiel auf den
publication weist den wie vorhin schon
besprochen haben unterm strich waren die
kritiker der meinung dass viele der
klinischen studien über antidepressiva
nicht so aussagekräftig oder verlässlich
sein wie angenommen das heißt auch eine
wirkung über den placebo-effekt hinaus
sei noch nicht wasserfest
ich weiß es ist sehr unbefriedigend wir
waren selbst ein bisschen überrascht wie
schlecht die datenlage ist was machen
wir jetzt daraus zwischen rettung und
reinfall um den deutschen leitlinien zur
behandlung einer unipolaren depression
werden antidepressiva bei leichteren
fällen eher nicht empfohlen es gibt
ausnahmen zum beispiel der patient
wünscht es sich oder hat schon gute
erfahrungen gemacht aber bei akut
mittelgradigen oder akut schweren
depressionen werden antidepressiva als
behandlung oder zusatzbehandlung
durchaus empfohlen es gibt ein argument
das man immer wieder hört die
studienlage mark unklar seien aber in
der praxis sehen wir doch ganz deutlich
dass antidepressiva wenn auch nicht
allen einigen menschen sehr klar hilfen
und das ist doch das was zählt das ist
ja im prinzip dass wer heilt hat recht
argument das auch oft in der
alternativmedizinischen szene zum
beispiel bei homöopathie kann verwendet
wird und warum man das so nicht
durchgehen lassen kann haben wir in
diesem video ziemlich ausführlich
erklärt und das ist nicht die einzige
parallele
viele zu alternativmedizin argumenten
oft hört man auch depressionen sind so
komplex und von mensch zu mensch so
unterschiedlich da kann man ja gar nicht
mit standardisierten studien in denen
jeder gleich behandelt wird irgend etwas
wertvolles herausfinden darüber wie man
menschen in der praxis in der
wirklichkeit behandeln ist nämlich ganz
individuell das leuchtet irgendwie ein
und in der praxis werden depressionen
auch sehr individuell behandelt sie das
video aber dass eine krankheit so
individuell ist dass man sie nicht
wissenschaftlich ordentlich untersuchen
könnte
das kann man so natürlich nicht sagen
trotzdem kann man antidepressiva
natürlich nicht mit homöopathika oder
anderen alternativen wundermitteln
vergleich dem wir das beispiel partie
die berufen sicher im gegensatz zu
antidepressiva nicht auf
wissenschaftliche studien die ein key
review durchlaufen haben oder auf
klinische studien die ordentlich
durchgeführt werden oder einen
zulassungsprozess ja es gibt ja noch
nicht mal eine nachgewiesene
physiologische wirkung gesehen von einem
erhöhten insulinspiegel blo blo die
überdosis
es gibt ja noch nicht einmal einen
theoretischen wirkmechanismus der
irgendwie biochemisch plausibel ist
antidepressiva hingegen basieren auf
ordentlicher forschung sind aber noch
nicht ausreichend verstanden weswegen
ich da schon verständnisvoller bin wenn
man sagt mir geht es damit besser und
dafür bin ich einfach nur dankbar
antidepressiva sind keine wundermittel
also wenn das so wäre dann hätten wir
auch eine klarere daten lag das heißt
aber gleichzeitig dass man nicht
grundsätzlich für antidepressiva angst
haben muss oder dass man sie definitiv
als wirkungslose abstempeln letztendlich
muss man alles auch im kontext der
schwere der krankheit sehen also wie gut
oder schlecht es euch damit geht wenn
ihr selbst von einer depression
betroffen seid und dazu bereit seid eure
erfahrungen in den kommentaren zu teilen
dann wird man allein schon beim lesen
der kommentare feststellen
wie unerträglich schwer diese krankheit
sein kann
deswegen sollte man unbedingt mit einem
arzt über alle möglichkeiten und auch
über alle ängste und sorgen offen
spricht in der endart verlinke ich euch
gleich noch die videos und psychologie
kundtut doku schaute unbedingt vorbei
aber vorher gibt es noch ein kleines ins
match habt ihr alle die halle kassel
nehmen können sich die freunde der sonne
es gibt große neuigkeiten und zwar haben
wir einen meidet ihn vergrößerung ja
schon länger meint schaute war es
natürlich bescheid und kennt wähler
niveaus melanie melanie melanie ist
natürlich unsere grafikerin offiziell
ist melanie unsere betreuung der
redakteurin of funk und swr seite und
führt es auch sehr auf die sehr wichtige
nicht wissenschaftliche stimme wählen
wir in unseren köpfen gefangen sind und
nicht mehr in die realität um das mache
ich sehr gerne ja dann könnt ihr
natürlich gar als promovierter biologe
und schlaf forscher seit anfang 2009 10
vollzeit meile teammitglied und jetzt
hab ich die mitglied und zwar hier
doktor jens wohlgemerkt hier ist es auch
promovierte wissenschaftler also für
euch nur das beste freunde der sonne
tendenz seines zeichens psychologe und
hirnforscher aus dem sonnigen
schwabenland und inzwischen im noch
sonnigeren florida durch freue mich
wirklich extrem
mein wunsch ist dass ich in diesem team
der das vierte tischbein am tisch sein
kann und nicht zum beispiel dafür die
indiana jones filmen tisch wackelt
was ich damit aber ich freue mich
einfach sehr sehr teil des teams zu sein
dann haben wir versucht jetzt als
willkommen das ritual ein cookie zu
geben aber das hat zur mittel gut
funktioniert verblüffend realistisch
dankeschön dankeschön dankeschön dafür
waren ja nicht explizit zu kaufen jetzt
kommen auch der große test wie endet
jedesmal video herzlich willkommen
danke schön dass mit den cookies noch so
wiederholen
ich schneide es genau so zusammen wie
wiederholen hier gar nichts sicher